ci sono delle volte in cui aver pietro
in squadra sicuramente rimpiangere di
averlo conosciuto come persona stiamo
per giocare ragazzi a four nights che un
videogioco che ho già fatto che un
batter royale free to play e lo siamo
per ciò che di squadra io pietro e
thomas nella prima partita non ci sarà
thomas solo pietro e poi spunterà anche
lui poi vedete cosa è successo buona
visione
andiamo alle prigioni pietro no dai boss
ma la prigione il sito 321 via
fai qualcosa vuoi qualcosa a questo
scopo ha fatto eco a destra dove di
mazzante bene lui è andato al kalak a
madonna che brutta cosa visto aiuto
secondo me more rosa scusami cosa cosa
hai detto aiuto
e vabbè con la lanciato la bomba giusto
marca vacca pietro e la guerra
termonucleare globale si è rimasti 15
tensioni
ce la possiamo fare che lo sento
arrivare con l'esame tecnico aiuto
pietro aiuto non l'ha votato giu però
furono buttato gioielli che adesso
rianimato maledetti erano in due
maledizione 36 quando serve dovrei
andare anche casa per la solita noi
vorremmo sempre frenato destra qua in
alto a destra dove moriamo vai c'è solo
un team che sta nella e nelle case
opposte dai vogliamo stanare quelli
nell'altra casa occhio che qua c'è qua
dentro c'è una trappola senza centra la
pole a ci andrà poi in trocchio e l'ora
bravo sei perspicace occhio
l'ho colpito ma non è morto attenzione
ci sono ripari dino tron un modo per
buttarlo giù proprio ai ha mandato già
detto giu occhio l'altrove l'altro è
morto lo nucci kg ma quanta roba è
piovuta dal cielo ma va a cagare ritmi
sono cagate in mano e governa l'ho
marcato dietro morti ma bravo spera
l'altro bravo bravo mammamia cedevano
fucino leggendario fuci leggendaria non
l'avevo narcisista è un problema mio ha
redento pronto alle band che figo pero
secondo fuori guarda ma che figata extra
giusta sembra il sottosopra chi sarà in
certi insegniamo a morire mai per lei
piuss per le news provai avanti tu li
ricorda quanto troppo le faccio io il
casino che c'è quando si arriva a fine
partita quando arrivi tra i primi dieci
coppa prof
c'è un lancia fufi leggendario grazie
pietro parlarmi coperto wise bara una
terra l'altro indietro maledizione
bravissimi che forti occhio che dalle
sempre l'edificio si trova sfogo tra
capire a nord è morto è morto è morto
uno subito ma così
missile
arriva verso l'idea pietro occhio
devo come la minore o una capito anzi
quattro ha capito io però spara gli
esclusi gli ho lanciato una zucca su 12
gare sono qui sotto un divino io ho
visti la lievissima 12 sotto lori daino
erano visti di vedere che male c'è che
la star ha tenuto c'è guerra è questa
aiuto
trovate il link per scaricare i giochi
descrizione agli ora gli sparano a me sì
quando metà quanta vita aveva è stato un
bel tentativo di thomas in partita
eccolo noi due siamo le donne tu no e
vero in questa casa che porta fortuna 19
ma io prima io prima io prima io per me
ho vinto di tumore semi che ancora suse
trovato tre bombe intendete intendo
questa sorella buona perché è la sorella
pietro e una sorella che si chiama
franca e non dice mai la verità lo sai
perché sempre franca no perché
francamente ho colpito
adesso c'è adesso che sia morto fai
parte bene e la prima è andata come sto
dong ha mostrato un arrivato un fucile
sardo leggendario misurazione attenzione
dietro aspettando che ok ok ok ci sia
una granata
ecco l'ho provata trovate il link per
scaricare i giochi dice bugie
leggendario io quello è mio grazie e tom
devo vedere dove l'ultimo tizio modello
denotiamo a questo file incassano
deluderemo 600 della finestra ora te lo
diamo ok perfetto ma che è uccisa fosse
la nascita senza altra finestra o pietro
ferrero pietro cosa trovi il link del
gioco in descrizione fate vi dico la
società aternativa guardate come agorà
distrutto e carmen perché il suo gioco è
tutto distruttibile l'approdo a sparare
ma non c'è dentro coprimi pietro ma non
solo
quasi un onore se è vicinissimo e mi sto
avvicinando ma che male chiamare di
nuovo arrivo tra tre secondi ingaggi del
posto va da sinistra per la 1 sezione
arrivati arrivati e eccolo la dizione ne
manca uno dei colpi secondo me è già
dentro qualcuno scrutini a chiamare ma
sei stato tu a l'ho visto da al 60 dagli
alberi a 60 arriva gente ma di quello
che noi siamo ragazza un gruppo sul
tetto c'è una roba
c'è un barattolo di nutella arachidi
d'arachidi arachidi succo succoso si
chiama è veramente porca vacca sul
cecchino qua ho preso subito la dizione
la pistola di nonna papera ragazzo da un
cecchino non so come difendermi all
io la pista linea carpo cena vai via da
centro milione su cosa regalare per
favore chiudendo in sala arriva diciamo
e ma arrivando caro andiamo a salvare
pietro a salvare pietro perche si
rilassa noi siamo di qua allora uno
dietro a casa poi
usciamo un cecchino epico prendi la
smettete di demolire qualsiasi corda
guarda ora guarda ora l'ultimo poi non
quale fisica ed aspetta aspettare se non
ci credo sappiamo che per il link per
scaricare giochi descrizione top da me
non ci posso credere l'ho detto e mi
sono trovato quattro si rifaccia dai a
terra
la terra bene ancora uno non so dove sia
ad arcavacata la casa compreso perché
stuprata e uccisa o ucciso non capisco
cosa stai dicendo
ma perché sia per terra
non avevo capito dagli la carezza ai
miei carezze rianimano le persone non
troppo linking descrizione e anche nel
primo commento che vale facciamo una
cosa voglia controllare alla fattoria pa
sinistra su gente li stai facendo e lo
scarso incredibilissimo cosa hai
costruito niente io ti trovo le robe tu
che ti costruisci la roba sfruttamento
questo lurido maledetto vieni qua c'è un
drop dalla giu si prende come prende
come prenderlo ma mantiene apre a
svegliare sfruttarmi apre non morire io
per te l'ho fatta ma l'hai fatta una
porta si apre questa sparano pietro
aiuto mg bravissimi ha forse giocato
si salvi chi può mamma mia che brutta
roba via sezione di ascoli c'è tutta la
fai pietro sulla destra rimediata ce
l'ho ce l'ho appena se la sete ma quanta
gente e da dove tra partito uno di
primato tra martino colori prima maglia
da secoli odio vabbè rimane rimane a
leffe rimane a letto di no no no no no
no no no no aspetta
eccola una facciata o le grande pietro
di serie 3 contro 1 sindaco tra loro e
si tramandano interdette e hanno beccato
e non pensavo facesse passino niente no
dai
e lotito la roccia non fare sta cosa i
ragazzi questo era il video di port
night
io veramente non appare pietro ha messo
cioè non ha ormai non ha più senso quel
ragazzo non ha veramente volevo dirvi
siccome è comunque già un po che porto
forni sul canale è disponibile sia per
pc che per playstation che per xbox che
per me che c'è per qualsiasi cosa ed è
completamente free to play quindi se
volete provarlo il link per lascio nella
descrizione del video e anche nel primo
commento come se non l'avesse capito
durante il video e questo lo sanno bene
anche thomas e pietro però che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi consenso più
sull'argomento mi piace anche vari
social che mi ha dato né descrizione ciò
che si scrive che ci vediamo al prossimo
vita beh ragazzi
[Musica]